Một giờ hôm nay mừng gắng hát hai năm 2019,
không cạnh rất đưa chá tuổi phạm về mặt khi công a kỳ bố xí Minh của hợp hơn vị tính thành kìm chá hình chính quan bà
e plớ chơi địa bàn phương cộng hãn thử tự hành công tác.
Thưa điểm kìm chà, cơ sự đang hoạt động với hôn năm獎 hết phẩm nhìn viên.
Qua kìm chà và xế nghiệm ngành, lực lượng trích năng bà đầu rất liện với bẩy trình hộp có kết quả dân tính quả trích mặt dưới.
Đồng thời phát hiện hai trình hộp vi vẫn tặng trữ trẻ phép trích mặt dưới.
Hẹn các tộc quan trích năng đăng phí tục đưa chá tu tập tài liệu,
chính cứ nhằm làm gió từ hình vi cụ thể cho phí định của phóc lợp.
Bảo đam với quan, lượng hình viên không làm anh gồn đến hả động hộp phá của các tổ chức,
cã nhên không đến quan.
Hó đồng kìm chà thì hiện quyết tâm cao của công a thịp của xí Minh trong công tác phòng ngừa,
lâu chân với tội phạm và tế nạn mà tui,
phó phần dữ tự án đi, chật tự.
Bảo vệ cuộc sống mình íng của những dân trong dịch tế của xin biến hộn năm 2019,
trong hai mì sấu đăng cật kì, năng tự mục tiêu xe dựng tình phó không mặt tối và năng cành hình khu chân bà mười.